شكرا جزيلا
نادين وسهام وايضا محمد ودينا ومهيره تحت
في الدور الارضي شكرا لكم اني انا جمعت
فيكم من زمان والله زمان والله زمن
بداياتي كانت
اول مره اول ما اجيت على على دبي من
الكويت كان عشان نقدم صباح العربيه مع بعض
انا كاني فتره عم بقدر خمسه بعد هيك ثلاث
اربع شهور من ما انا بلشت اقدم صباح
العربيه لا انبسطنا كتير انا وعادل وعادل
طبعا اللي ما بيعرفوا دمه خفيف كتير كتير
عنده روح النكته فطول الوقت وانا قاعده
جنبه واحنا قاعدين بنقدمه انا يعني رح
اموت من الضحك دايما قاعد هلا
على الجبس كينج بيحتفل بالعربيه وهو دائما
الحياه سعيده اذا ما كانت سعيده لابد ان
نراها سعيده اليوم احنا نحتفل يمكن انا
واحد من الناس اقول انه كانت في بداياتي
اول ما اجيتي الى دبي مش في ال2005 جيت
قبلها قبل انطلاقه العربيه ايضا كان في
شهر اكتوبر اعتقد او نوفمبر كنت كمراسل
بالكويت صحيح قبل انطلاقه العربيه حتى كان
في اجراءات انه بالجزء هذاك ممنوع انه
ندخل نشوف
اللوك او الشكل الجديد
للعربيه وكان استديو الاخبار المذيعين
كانوا يعملوا دائما هذه يعني
خلينا نقول التمرين اللي هو ما يسبق
الهواء وكل شيء اختلف ما بعد
ك
شباب بعد
لو سمحت شباب وصبايا
سنتحدث الان عن الاكل لانه انت صار لك
ساعه عم بتشهينا
سنتحدث عن الاكل ثوره هائله في طريقه
تناول الناس للطعام والخيارات المتاحه
اصبحت اكثر تنوعا في العقدين الماضيين من
الوجبات السريعه الى الاطعمه العضويه الى
الوجبات النباتيه الى الماكولات الغريبه
من جميع انحاء العالم وحتى الصراصير
تخيلوا التي دخلت قوائم الطعام مؤخرا
قبلها شطر يجي
لا لا
مجموعه خيارات الطعام توسعت بشكل كبير
ازدادت شعبيه الانظمه الغذائيه التي تركز
على الصحه مثل النباتيين اصبح الناس
يتخذون المزيد من القرارات حول ما
ياكلونها
انتشار الانترنت كمان وتطبيقات مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وظاهره تصوير الطعام
اللي هلا دارجه كتير ادوا لتغيير النظره
الى الطعام ليصبح الطعام ثقافه تشجع الشخص
على تجربه الاطعمه التي يراها مش بس هيك
يا ماذا ايضا هي اتاحت طبعا للكثير من
التطور التكنولوجي التطبيقات وخدمات
التوصيل مشاهدينا اتاحت الامكانيه الوصول
الى جميع انواع الماكولات من جميع انحاء
العالم وايضا تسليمه الى باب منزلك
في صباح العربيه اطلقنا حربا من نوع اخر
حرب هي حرب الطعام قبل ان نستضيف ضيفنا
المميز اليوم من غير اطباقه لنذهب الى حرب
طعام جديده بين السعوديه والاردن العنوان
جدا جدا جدا بسيط صباح العربيه في طبق
ولكن من ذهب
[موسيقى]
قد يكونوا فطورا تقليديا لكنه يحمل معه
تفاصيل الصباح رائحه خبيز التقليدي تجمعنا
معكم من الاردن وتخطيات اي مسافات
صباح العربيه في طبق وانا اخترت طبق
الجريش السعودي المبتكر مع الريش المشويه
مع الشيف العالمي منصور اسماعيل
[موسيقى]
تحضير العجين بحب اول شرط من شروط اعداد
اقراص الزعتر البلدي
[موسيقى]
رائحه الزعتر وزيت الزيتون توثق الكثير من
ذكريات هذه الاقراص
[موسيقى]
طبقات من الزعتر والعجين تنتهي مرحله
تحضيرها الاخيره في الفرن لون الحمره يعني
النهايه اقراص الزعتر تجهزت لتعلن صباح
يوم جديد
[موسيقى]
اليوم راح نسوي الجريش الابيض لكن راح
نستخدم معاه الريش المقادير راح نستخدمها
طبعا حب الجريش رشه كمون بسيطه السمن
البصل والليمون الاسود هذا راح يكون
للحشوه اللي من فوق طبعا والمويه
الجريش اعتمدته هيئه فنون الطهي طبقا
وطنيا للسعوديه انطلاقا من قيمته
التاريخيه والاجتماعيه والغذائيه الشيخ
منصور اسماعيل ساهم في اعداد كتاب سفره
المائده السعوديه بشراكه مع هيئه فنون
الطهي التابعه لوزاره الثقافه
الجريش الابيض بريش طبق يليق بصباح
العربيه اعيد العربيه العشرين والطبق زي
ما انتم شايفين يشكي ويحكي ويسول
[موسيقى]